alright I welcome you my name is Steve
Bloomfield I'm executive director of the
weather had center for international
affairs and I'm very happy to see all of
you at the food plus research symposium
Henry thorough said I have great faith
in a seed convince me that you have a
seed there and I'm prepared to expect
wonders about six years ago I asked Rob
pearlberg to come to my office because
he had been running a long time seminar
that seemed to be running its course and
I said Rob what can we do next that will
be of interest to you and Rob said well
I've been doing a lot of work on food
politics and perhaps we could fashion
something together on that we had a long
conversation about the prospects and the
opportunities of that perhaps the
unlikely idea that food research could
be carried on in such a place as Harvard
University and not michigan state
university or iowa state university but
we put our feelers out and we found
first missy Holbrook in the faculty of
arts and sciences and she said she would
sign up and next we found John Briscoe
sorry to say the late John Briscoe who
had recently come to Harvard to work on
all manner of water resources and he
said he would like to participate and
the word went out slowly and surely such
that we had great companionship from
bill clark and the sustainability
science program at the Harvard Kennedy
School and it went on and on so we've
had a symposium of sorts for about six
years as I say with faculty and visitors
from afar talking about their food
research their concerns about
sustainable agriculture and it's come to
a kind of
frooition from having had that faith in
this seed to today where it's grown to
something of an enormity that we had not
expected certainly six years ago and
maybe I think at least speaking for
myself even six weeks ago so we have a
really wonderful opportunity here today
to get a sense of their food research
that's going on around this university
and indeed the wider community hoping to
plant further seeds to prove the worth
of the work that's going on here and the
worth of the curiosity that's here as
well as in the general community hoping
to advance food research agricultural
research for many years to come we hope
that you stay in your seats throughout
have good questions that I'm afraid
you're not going to be able to address
right here and now as a result of the
presentations but that you leave with
those questions and continue to address
them within the community so that we can
continue to advance this good cause I'm
very happy to see all of you here I want
you to stick with us till four-thirty
and then after the symposium at our
reception that's going to follow closely
behind thanks for coming
thank you see my name is Bill Clark come
on the faculty of the Kennedy School
here at Harvard and as Steve noted one
of the ringleaders in this particular
venture as Steve said the the origins of
this particular gathering was a was a
simple relatively small-scale seminar
that my colleague Rob pearlberg took the
lead in of trying to bring together
people across disciplines around the
Harvard community and then increasingly
engaging our colleagues at Tufts and MIT
in discussions of where the world food
system was headed so forth and so on and
this week we built on the long legacy
that had been constructed by Ray
Goldberg will be our last speaker today
down at the business school setting up
Harvard as a place that people from the
community of non-governmental
organizations the business sector
scholars are human rights organizations
and so on came together what became very
clear to us though was that this little
occasional evening seminar was not
beginning to tap in to the wealth of
research that was available in the
region here or even in our own
University and though other fields like
my energy like social policy had logical
and energetic places to come together
and share perspectives share research
perspectives across disciplines and so
on for various reasons that had not
emerged organically at Harvard and so
this is this is one of Steve's seeds we
started talking around about our vague
impression that there was an awful lot
of research happening in this university
in the nexus of food and the things that
connects with nutrition health
environment foreign affairs trade issues
and so on and discovered very rapidly
that though we thought there was a lot
there turned out to be vastly more than
we had even imagined out
head of us from the blocks were the
students as usual were a number of
activities like the ones run through the
law school we'll hear something about
later today the president's initiative
on innovations for the world food system
but lacking in that was what this event
has come together around which is a
celebration of faculty research on the
topic meant to complement those efforts
based in what our students are doing
activism movements the food justice
program and so on this word cloud is
made up of the topics you will hear
spoken on today these are in fact the
titles of the talks somewhat more
jumbled than I hope they will sound when
they're presented to you but the point
is food at the center and almost any
imaginable line of work of research work
done in this university from stuff done
by the humanities to things that the
medical school two things here in the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences so what
we've done confronted by that
embarrassment of riches is retreated to
what many of you will experienced in
other professional meetings which is a
so-called speed presentation format one
that is meant obviously not to dig
deeply into the evidence the methodology
and so on of the research underway but
to give us all a rapid taste of the
spectrum of kinds of research that are
going on the stuff that fills this angle
so the procedure today will be just that
a series of 20-something speed
presentations all of which our
presenters have assured us will be seven
minutes or less I have a gong over there
that will help us remind each other
about this mutual pledge because
otherwise we'll be here to the middle of
the night so we will try to do that
unfortunately that leaves no formal time
for Q&A from this audience and that
means we're going to miss a huge amount
of insight we've set up a Twitter
account which you'll see on your handout
we also will have at the website which
you'll see on your handout a place for a
blog where those of you like me who
don't do Twitter can do just submissions
of reactions to this suggestions for
whatever it should be doing next and so
on speak
when your time comes if you would go to
that end where Lauren is standing here
come up the stairs on that side and
around the back to here when you're done
walk off on my side and down the steps
there audience we don't have a break
today and it is going to go for four
hours so if you feel the urge or need to
exit and enter please do so at the back
in that corner and please try to make
your movements happening as we do the
switches up in front there are restrooms
out in the corridor essentially behind
this screen so you can circle around
outside that said we'll do a bunch of
thanks to the enormous number of both
institutions programs and crucially
staff and other individuals who have
been behind making this happen at the
end of the presentations today and you
saw some of those things on the rotation
of slides going on but without further
ado let me turn us to our first
presenter professor Dan schrag of the
theft of art since I said and you have
to get around back to kill yourself
coming up here yep learning you have to
sheep herd them that way and you'll set
the seven minute clock when you go